hear that Mariah Carey Audio Oh my God
no no they didn't want to talk about 9
11. it's one of my favorites ever it is
so [__] funny and everyone goes what
what they're murmuring what what you
want to know what's funny I was there
that was that Global citizen Fest no way
22. and she said that and I said what we
literally all looked around like why did
she just we're in New York why did she
say that I I can talk about a little bit
does she say we you can't talk about it
I can't talk about that oh I thought she
was like oh the audience doesn't want to
talk about like you don't want to talk
about 911 fine and I was like wait what
who was talking no one was should no one
mentioned it by the way we can't talk
back to you you're the only one on the
stage of the mic you can't hear us